so one of the common uh problems that we
see in the machine learning development
life cycle is the challenge of going
from research to production and and
machine learning might need to modernize
and refactor their code multiple times
uh before it reaches to production and
sometimes this might actually require
them to re-implement certain features or
maintaining uh feature engineering of at
multiple places uh which again can take
a lot of time and thinking about a
solution for this problem we can
actually take a lot of inspiration from
the web so the HTTP protocol which
basically standards is a way in which we
transfer the data across the internet
providing a backbone and methods that
are clearly defined similarly uh can we
actually build a similar kind of a
pipeline for machine Learning Systems
where we had a protocol for basically
building and deploying machine learning
uh applications at scale so uh
specifically that is where I'll be
introducing today uh the uni nml
platform and I'll quickly also go over
what exact exactly does that Union ml
platform convey so first of all what
exactly is Union ml uh Union ml is
basically an open source mlapse mlops
framework that kind of reduces the
boiler uh reduces the boilerplate and
complexity when it comes to basically
building and deploying models to uh
production and it helps us to actually
set a different uh set of functions and
methods that are commonly used for
machine learning and they could be used
for multiple context uh right from model
training to production so basically
Union Union ml unifies all this ever
growing ecosystem of machine learning
and data tools into a single interface
to be able to create very easy to use
and simple to deploy uh and produce
machine learning based microservices and
that that is what the union ml platform
does now let's take a look at how you
can basically get started with Union ml
so the first thing that you can do is
very easily install the in the a package
which is PIP install unanimal and then
you can start by creation of a union ml
application and now let's break down
what uh way or like how does a union ml
app actually looks like so the first one
is that you can install the data
dependencies whatever dependencies you
might acquire again since we are working
with machine learning based apps uh you
can use any machine learning framework
of your choice whether it's Pi torch
tensorflow sk-learn whatever is your
choice you can use that the next one
that we'll do is that we'll basically
create our data set so this this is
where we are preparing ourselves uh for
our training data set our uh data that
will go into the model and then of
course the model of our choice in this
case and the example that is being
showcased is a digital classifier where
you're using uh logs regression uh the
next thing that we'll Define a certain
set of decorator methods now these are
primarily focused on uh there are four
different methods right from uh reading
our data set and then of course uh
evaluating our data set and running the
actual machine learning models so the
first decorator function that you'll
find is uh the reader method that's used
to actually read our data set the next
one is where we basically go ahead and
initialize our machine learning model
and the next one that you'll see is our
prediction uh decorator where we are
going to be making a prediction
and finally we have uh the last
evaluator model which is The Decorator
for evaluating our machine learning
model so the common thing that you see
here is that by defining these decorator
functions we are having separate machine
learning capabilities that we usually
have as part of any machine learning
end-to-end application which has
separate methods defined and we have
these separate uh separate decorators
that in which you can actually Define
any type of machine learning model and
of course any prediction that you want
to use and then uh this kind of
showcases the end-to-end union ml app
right from importing our dependencies
and then of course defining our
decorator functions now of course this
is not the state uh now when it comes to
actually going ahead and deploying or
running these applications uh these
entire end-to-end ml apps you can either
uh deploy them with the help of a fast
API or even serverless functions
um and of course you can then also make
them uh go ahead and actually
productionize them uh productionize
these microservices and these are the
common ways that you can do so either
you can create a web endpoint with the
help of fast API or streamlit or you can
also create a serverless endpoint for
these or if you want to basically go
ahead and deploy them on a flight
cluster uh on a kubernetes cluster uh
creating like end-to-end uh ml Ops
orchestration platform you can use uh
something known as flight which is
basically a machine learning
orchestration orchestrator for machine
learning and data pipelines again which
is an open source project so you have
all of these different ways in which you
can do that and these are the set of
Integrations so again the idea for Union
ml is to create a set of Integrations
that allows you to use any platform or a
tool that you use in your end-to-end
machine learning uh Pipeline and then
all of add all of that into a single
application so that your single app can
do all the things including your model
Discovery and then model training model
evaluation and then of course going
ahead and deploying the model uh from
the same app and over here you can see
that you have for deployment you get
also a number of different other tools
that include your machine learning
Frameworks and also if you are
integrating your uh machine learning
Pipeline with let's say Apache uh or
even with a databases so you can also
connect with those or even have like
serverless functions as well and
this is the kind of the roadmap uh for
this project where you could do things
like model serving model tuning uh right
from this particular project now what
I'll also quickly showcase is a quick
demonstration of the code base itself so
uh this is a python notebook that I have
and over here it's pretty much uh the
same uh the same things that we covered
in the slides so in the first section I
have
um the actual importing of my uh all the
dependencies and then I'm initiating my
data set in which basically you can see
that I Define it by the name of the
digital data set and then uh the model
which I've named as it's classifier and
in the next cell I have all of my
decorator functions for reading for
training for predicting and for
evaluating and finally what I've done is
I have gone ahead and actually run my
job and in the last uh one you can see
that in this case I am going to be
deploying this particular ml app with
the help of fast API so again the way
you'll go ahead and do this is that once
you have created your app just go ahead
and use Union ml serve which will allow
you to serve this app and again
depending on whatever backend uh
framework you have chosen for being able
to deploy this app you can use that in
this case it's fast API and it works
very well so again the main motive of
Union ml is to basically unify all the
different set of machine learning tools
that you use and have this one single
app that you can very easily then go
ahead and deploy and productionize that
app regardless of whatever machine
learning framework you might use
foreign
with that I'll conclude my talks so give
me one second and uh and in case you
want to get involved you can basically
go ahead and start the project on
github.com Union AI OSS Union ML and you
can also check out the docs in case you
are interested uh to take a look at the
union ml Docs but that's it from man
thank you so much